The answers are get, keep, and grow--are the three parts of customer relationships.
As we'll see, customer relationships start with get.
Get is how you actually acquire customers and get them to purchase your product.
Keep--just like it sounds.
How do you keep customers for long period of time rather than losing the ones
you've spent all the money acquiring?
And then grow is a neat trick that smart companies do--is that they understand that it's a lot
more expensive to get customers than to keep them and grow them.
And so they figure out how to sell existing customers more products.
Get, keep and grow--the three components of customer relationships.